if you had to go up against Mother
Nature on crack what would you do you're
going to have to juggle battling Force
demons brutal Samurai guys and just
plain old baddies using nothing but
innocent children as weapon a
500-year-old book on power banned by the
Catholic church I'm going to break down
the mistakes made what you should do and
how to beat the fource spirit in
Princess monoke this kid has no idea
he's about to be infected with a
horrifying killer disease that will set
him on the adventure of a lifetime as
Ashi taka here is a noble Prince for his
people the amishi tribe unaware that a
flesh eating Spirit God is on his way to
rushing back from a patrol mission on
his trusty sidekick yakul he quickly
warns his people that something
horrifying is coming their way but he
doesn't know what reaching The Scouting
post he teams up with this Soldier
taking out his bow suddenly a demon
blasts out from the forest shocking
ashitaka to the bone this boar is
possessed it crashes into the scouting
post forcing these two to helplessly
watch as it heads straight towards his
precious Village getting on yakul he
dashes like the wind but the Scout tries
to warn him to not touch the cursed
Spirit no matter what or else but that
was Ashi taka's biggest mistake closing
the Gap he sees these little kids about
to get devoured and Ashi taka fires a
single Arrow to distract it and this
causes the demon to fire ranged attack
at him striking his arm and him wincing
in pain he shoots a final Arrow into the
demon putting it down for good saving
the day but then he realizes that uh
whoops he just messed up he's now been
cursed and the village Shaman rushes
over to pay respects to the bore God but
the demon inside tells him that soon all
of humanity will feel its wrath
including Ashi taka and the people he
loves now and in the future okay Ashi
Taka was dumb as bricks the way his
Prince butt acted if I was him I would
have saved everybody the trouble by
letting some of the jobless loser
taxpayers die a horrible death let me
explain so this local Village contains a
dying tribe and means they're pretty
much toast but if they're toast then
maybe they should have fortified their
Villages a little more since well let's
be honest most peaceful tribes in
history unfortunately usually get
absolutely slaughtered they should have
structured their Village more like the
first Common castles before the 10th
Century using wood and would have
featured a very lovely Palisade and a
wooden Tower with a potential mod I love
modes and maybe another sanction
functioning as a self-sustaining mini
Fortress AKA a citadel you know the last
line of defense type of thing and would
have helped keep the villagers safe even
the poor innocent kids but since they're
too freaking peaceful for their own good
there's another way they could have
saved the prince and it has to do with
The Village's defenses for starters
don't you think it might have been a
better idea to have more than one man up
on the Watchtower yeah I would think so
because then it would have allowed them
to signal to the village and said hey
there's a problem coming at a much
faster rate because it's clear that even
if this Watchtower spot itself he would
have been way too slow to warn them fast
enough ashitaka has to stupidly go after
a demon by himself and this means that
Ashi taka from the get-go should have
been less patriotic and thinking more
critically about his actions because
he's the prince he's way more important
than some snotty no kids here who just
Happ to eat sleep and chill on the tax
pair's dime which makes them bigger
wasteful citizens if I was him I would
have taken the useless Scout with me
earlier to use as a helping hand and
would have slowed the monster down by
letting him feed on The Souls of these
stupid kids here and during this moment
I would have fired some shot shot into
the monster like the stud that I view
myself to be and naturally I will expect
it to react in pain is going to try to
attack us and right at that moment we're
going to toss our useless Scout right at
it because he is useless which will keep
it distracted for a moment longer and
allow me to fire the killing shot and
take it out for good later that night
Ashi taka heads to the shaman but
receives bad news using her powers she
tells him that the bore God came from
the west and was infected by some kind
of poison that drove him mad and they
find this iron bullet inside of his
corpse and this was the reason he was in
so much pain and why eventually turned
into a demon rage and anger caused this
but ashitaka has little time to figure
out her cryptic talking and he discovers
that the injury on his arm is cursed and
soon the infection will spread and
brutally peel the flesh off of his bones
killing him unless he sets off on an
adventure and does one thing follow
where the Bor God came from and head
West and be set free from hate but once
he does this he has a 30% chance of
lifting his curse but before he goes she
warns him that something evil is at work
where he's going and once he leaves
because of their Village rules he may
never return there G aren't they nice
thank you for your service man now get
out but ashitaka gets sad for like 10
anime seconds and leaves and he bumps
into a sister on the way out who gives
him her Crystal dagger to remember her
and then he sets off to save his soul
retracing the bore God's steps he soon
passes by a village right in the middle
of an allout Massacre of women children
men screaming and decapitation and a lot
of Galore and a whole lot of gask Khan
level of horror on alert these evil
soldiers spot him forcing him to haul
ass he quickly whips out his bow and
arrow to save this innocent villager but
something happens to his infected arm
just as he fires this Arrow straight
into this enemy soldier his hands clean
off with an impossible shot shocking him
and everyone around him with his
superhuman strength and he now realizes
that he's actually turning into a demon
well what Ashi taka here just felt is a
sign of a much bigger and more deadly
problem and a problem that he is not
thinking about and it has to do with the
zombie antivirus and how we really are
basically designed like bugs I'll
explain the shaman he talked to seemed
to know him but in that case him leaving
to try and cure his curse was way too
dumb the least he could have done was to
ask the shaman more questions about what
he could expect from this disease since
in this case the disease was happening
inside a human and not an animal duh you
think they might have put that together
because it makes logical sense to assume
that the incoming symptoms would not
necessarily be the same as it was for
the boar the curse is low-key magic but
also seems crazy familiar to a real life
fungus disease called the zombie ant
fungus and this thing mind controls
insects and basically turns them into a
zombie last of a style however this
thing can actually affect humans as well
because we actually share a crazy amount
of our physiology with insects but the
way would happen inside of our bodies is
a little different and our higher
internal body temperature which means
that this and other viruses that kill
the board just now would probably kill
us in death since our body would be too
hot and too complex for the virus to go
zombie mode on us stoping at another
Village he tries to get some food
offering this woman gold instead of
money and this attracts the attention of
this man named jico he follows ashitaka
and tells him that he saw him earlier
fighting like a demon but he tells oh no
no he won't tell anybody and offers to
cook him dinner not revealing at all
that he will soon cost Ashi taka the
lives of everyone that he's about to
meet there he updates goo on his
situation and where he's going he he
then shows him the iron ball he found
inside of the Bor God and jico tells him
what he's up against there's a giant
forest west of here where a powerful
Spirit lives and looks after all of the
animals that live there Ancient Forest
Gods bigger than a horse carriage and
more powerful than a battleship it's a
dangerous place for humans and he warns
ashitaka that if his curse doesn't kill
him the force there might but if he
survives he might be able to get rid of
this curse the next morning Ashi taka
thanks Chico and heads off while jico
watches him with Sinister intent a
little later elsewhere this group of
villagers try to transport some rice
into their Town Iron Town how original
but that was also their biggest mistake
howls are hurt and they spot incoming
wolves headed their way massive
creatures the humans quickly realize
they're about to fight what they've all
came for the gods of the forest they
quickly fire their weapons forcing the
Wolves to split apart and this one
rushes through their human defenses and
throws the men off the cliff and they
head straight for the leader this woman
but she quickly aims her gun and Fires
at the monster chasing it off for good
allowing the group to go back to
transporting their rice so at the bottom
of this Cliff Ashi taka bumps into some
of the fallen soldiers from from the
wolf battle seeing them critically
injured and he tries to rescue them but
senses something dangerous nearby going
to check it out he realizes that these
animals are gods and spots one human
with them this girl getting spotted he
comes out and declares that he will not
harm them and asks if he has now reached
the realm of the forest Spirit but this
girl just tells him to piss off and
disappears into the forest and that's
when screams are heard and he rushes to
the aid of these men and sees them
freaking out over this little creature
but he tells them to chill out because
this creature is known as a Kodama
Spirit to bring good luck on her sign
that this Forest is healthy good to know
but this injured Soldier here is still
tense and worries that this thing will
bring the leader of the forest to them
and Ashi taka's ears perk up and asks
what is he mean the creature that runs
this Forest looks like a giant deer that
sometimes has the face of a human but he
thinks these soldiers talking a little
crazy and he has no idea that this giant
deer is going to kill thousands very
soon using his tracking skills him and
the injured men make their way through
the dangerous forest and he spots the
girl and the Wolves tracks nearby
signaling that they must live close by
too and that's when he sees a deer in
the distance but something is off about
it his arm starts freaking out
uncontrollably and forces him to put it
into the water to calm down and he looks
back up but sees nothing where did to go
he carries on with his journey but then
he realizes that the man he's carrying
suddenly doesn't feel heavy anymore and
that's when they reach the Soldier's
Village named iron town and there all
the town's people show up finding out
that Ashi taka here is a hero and they
cheer for him and Lady abosi the town
ruler comes out to greet him and she
thanks him for saving her men and asks
to come talk to her later tonight that
night Ashi taka rested up and talks to
the other Town's folk while the ladies
augle at him because he's a stud the men
here tell him that lady ibosi went
around buying up all the contracts of
all the brothel workers nearby now
spoils all of them rotten she's trying
to make this town even more famous than
it is for its high quality Iron but some
of the men complained that everything
has gone to [__] since she took over
warning Ashi taka that she has no fear
Against The Gods of the forest and since
the iron around them has been used up
she started deforesting the nearby area
to extract more of it pissing off Forest
Gods like Nago and other animals this
information suddenly makes Ashi taka's
arm burning in pan and he thinks this
means that Nago the bore God he met
earlier must have died with hate in his
heart okay wow so lady AB here just
exhibited the Cardinal mistake of what
she's trying to achieve she just
exhibited two big red flags that make
her goals stupid as hell she could have
avoided all of this if she just treated
her environment like a small office
cubicle let me explain the number one
red flag that we just discovered about
lady iosi relates to an old 16th century
guide on how to be a true leader and
gain power of a country it's from the
book The Prince is a good book and one
of its most famous sayings is that the
best Fortress Is to be found in the love
of the people because the Fortress will
not save you if you are hated by the
people and this means that lady abosi
here as the leader of iron toown has
already failed to gain support and Trust
of her people it means even her forces
are not aligned and secure in helping
her achieve her goals and now on to Red
Flag number two it's got to do with Lady
osi's lack of fear towards the forest
and what it's capable of it's clear as a
leader she's not able to peacefully
coexist with nature and means that her
kingdom is living on borrow time let's
imagine lady bshi and her people are
working in an office and the forest is
their powerful boss her and her people
are coexisting in the same space as
someone much more influential and
powerful than her and her crazy
willingness to go above and beyond the
call of duy to try and make the boss
look bad by destroying the boss is a
direct example of her trying to outshine
the boss being Ashi taka here we just
witness two big red flags in the span of
a two-minute conversation with this
crazy lady which means I'm going to just
nod and smile and play nice and don't
waste any more time hearing what lady
abosi has to say because I want to be on
my way out of here ASAP going to meet
lady abosi she tells him that this town
is constantly under attack from people
trying to steal their iron or boohoo and
they think he's either a spy for wolf
girl or he works for the neighboring
enemies Lord asano Samurai Army but he
confesses that he's here because of this
demon Mark and takes out the iron bullet
that he found in the Bor God and tells
her it belongs to her people and she
laughs at him and tells him she'll show
them what her people are really up to
and shows him her private garden and
reveals that she is developing the most
advanced weapons on Earth in order to
kill the forc gods and Lord ofano
Samurai Army and any others they try and
stop her from what she's trying to
achieve world domination so ashitaka
gets a little bit pissed off at her for
being so freaking destructive and she
tells him that she's sorry her [__] got
him cursed but too bad it's just
business and that's when Ashi taka's arm
starts violently twitching again and
forces him to reach for his sword and
this makes everyone think that the
forest wants to kill lady bosi really
badly and that's when this old guy joins
in on the conversation and says that
while lady iosi is not perfect she's the
only one that saw their kind lepers as
human beings and was the only one who
took them into care for them and lady
ioshi then offers ashitaka a job and
says he should stay here and help her
kill the forest Spirits because this
will cause all the other gods of the
force to turn back into regular animals
and without any deficiencies she will
then be able to claim the richest land
on Earth and she also tells ashitaka
that the princess of the forest known as
Princess Mononoke will also turn back
into a human okay so what lady iosi is
doing right now is will not only destroy
the planet because that's such a great
idea it's even going to destroy the iron
industry which your town relies on great
lady abosi is clearly not thinking again
she just trying to kill the god of the
forest and she's also trying to destroy
the forest to make a quick Buck her
thinking is similar to what happened in
a small town in the Amazon rainforest
years ago like 1973 years ago it was
near this highway BR 319 basically
Society built a town there with a 550 M
Road connecting this town to the largest
city in the Amazon but ah within just a
few years nature took this whole town
back Jaguars anacondas deadly snakes
severe levels of malaria and rainfall
never seen before all showed up out of
nowhere causing most of the citizens to
escape and claiming that it seemed like
nature was fighting back and to this day
this town has been a living Nightmare
and it's an example of how nature is
actually way more powerful than we think
lady iosi destroying the forest is going
to affect her in ways that she cannot
even imagine in her small brain for
comparison once the Amazon reinforce
goes boom instantly these nine countries
are going to become unlivable and then
boom this affects the world's water
cycle and carbon balance because the
Amazon can hold 12 years worth of world
global emissions and then once that goes
boom Greenland IET is now gone and now
boom sea levels are rising and boom more
water caus degradation of Frozen soil in
the Arctic and then boom and this is
going to release dormant scary diseases
that were not prepared for to be
Unleashed and then boom rain is now 25%
lower boom temperature is Up by 4 and
1/2 Celsius and boom this causes rain in
other places to stop and then boom at
normal dry patterns of dry air moving
mixing up with wetter cooler air from
the south causing boom places like the
Gulf of Mexico to get wetter Than kiaro
Sex You know what in redo of the Healer
the point is that's 11 booms guys that's
a lot of booms this means that if lady
bosi gets rid of the land that she's
living on and makes money off of so much
that [__] is going to go south and
especially since this Forest is magical
and we all know that magic makes
everything go boom way more that's now
12 booms he then heads back downstairs
but then he hears something approaching
them fast it's wolf girl and the alarm
goes off and the town starts preparing
its defenses but wolf girl quickly
avoids getting shot and hops over the
massive wall my how impressive anyways
the villagers yell out that she is after
lady iosi and Ashi taka rushes to stop
her just as she gets shot and falls off
the roof running to protect her she
ignores his help and lunges at at lady
abosi and the two do get out some wolf
girl says that she needs to die for
destroying her Forest while the town's
folk around her tell her to die for
killing their people as well and both
sides get heated and Ashi taka finally
gets mad and approaches the two women
the town Captain here thinks Ashi taka
is a traitor and tries to kill him and
that's what activates his powers once
again and then he easily walks past him
and knocks both of the women out he
yells out that both of these women have
extreme anger within them and their
anger and fear is only making the demon
curse inside him grow stronger and he
hands lady ioshi to the tons folk and
tells them that he will be leaving and
taking the wolf girl with him and they
try to stop him and even shoot him but
his powers keep him going and he shocks
everyone he opened the front gate with
just one hand he tells the Wolves
waiting outside to chill out because
he's trying to save wolf girl thanking
the town's folk for Sheltering him they
ride off clearing enough distance
between them and the town Ashi taka
finally passes out because has of blood
loss and that's when wolf girl wakes up
and she yells at her wolves to not touch
him but angrily asks him why he tried to
save her he then says he didn't want
them to kill her and comments on how
beautiful she is freaking her out and
just then the a tribe of the forest show
up and declare that they want to eat
Ashi taka in order to gain his human
strength and Chase the other humans out
of the forest wolf girl tells them to
calm down but they refuse telling her
that they tried repopulating the area
with more trees and it hasn't worked and
now they're running out of time she
tells them that the force spirit will
save them but they think she's
delusional and they comment on how she
doesn't understand because she's human
at the end of the day and this pisses
off the Wolves as they chase the Apes
away wolf girl then tells her wolves to
also go home while she takes Ashi taka
to the forest to heal him nearby
ashitaka's friend from earlier jico sits
hiding with his men in animal costumes
well apparently they've been tracking
the force Spirit to figure out where it
lives seeing it for the first time the
men get scared but jico tells them to
sack up because the emperor of Japan
wants its head and they carefully watch
it transform from its alien body into
this deer and he begins to approach wolf
girl and the unconscious ashitaka as
they reach the area but suddenly Chico's
men see a Bor God near that they
regonize named okoto thinking this God
has been dead for 100 years Chico and
his men run from the scene in fear a
little a little later ashitaka wakes up
and realizes that his bullet wound is
gone well that's great but not his curse
crap wolf girl comes back and he finds
out from her that she can talk to
animals and finds out from his pet yakul
everything about him and where he comes
from she tells him that the four Spirits
brought him back to life which means it
wants him to live for some reason and
just then the Wolves show up but Circle
them to protect them against an incoming
threat the bore Gods showing up they
demand to know why the force Spirit just
saved the human when it didn't even save
their own kind the Wolves tell them that
the force Spirit knows best but they
think that's cap yo and think that the
wolf girl convinced the force Spirit to
save the human barely awake Ashi taka
tells them that he was the one that
killed their kind back in his village
named Nago when he found him he had
turned into a full-on demon and doesn't
know why the for Spirit saved him since
he will soon die anyways from the curse
on his arm and that's when the boss of
the Bor Gods named okoto shows back up
and senses that ashitaka isn't lying
about what happened to their own kind he
thanks him for putting Nago out of his
misery but tells him to leave the forest
or else the next time he won't show him
any Mercy wolf girl's mother named [__]
I mean Morrow tells okot that their kind
can't win against the humans but aoto is
stubborn and says they must still try
even if they're heading into a trap he
knows the Wolves won't help him and he
tells them to stay out of their way
while they prepare for the greatest
battle that this Forest has ever seen as
he heads off ashitaka finds old wolf
girl's real name son elsewhere lady
ioshi is working on fighting their
latest ongoing rival the samurai Army
trying to take over their time for their
iron lady ioshi uses her latest Weaponry
to chase them away for the 400th time
this month jigo and his men watch this
fight and begin to plan something
sinister he heads back to meet up with
Lady abosi after the battle and whines
to her that the emperor is breathing
down his neck about calling a truce with
Lord aso's Samurai but she tells him
that if she calls truce then she will
have to offer up half her iron and she
thinks he's up to something and he
assures her that he's on her side
because they have bigger problems than
humans because he heard that the bores
are preparing for a battle against their
town and he gets impatient and tells her
that she owes him for Lending her his
troops in exchange for going after the
force spear because Legend says its head
can grant the powers of immortality she
makes fun of them for thinking such a
power could even exist exist and this
annoys jico and forces him to politely
threaten her and possibly take away his
troops if she doesn't start following
the plan not trusting him she later
informs her ladies that they might soon
get betrayed when she's not around and
just in case they should prepare for
battle elter while son rests Ashi Taki
asks Moro why can't we all get along but
Morrow tells him the humans destroy
everything they touch he then finds out
that son will most likely die in the
coming War which pisses him off a lot
because he thinks she's cute he wonders
how she could let her own daughter die
but Morrow tells him that since she is a
part of the forest once the forest dies
so will she and warns him to leave her
since he will soon die and now can't do
anything anyways in the morning while
son and Morrow are out on a mission he
gets ready to leave but hands one of the
Wolves his necklace to give to son
elsewhere son and Morrow reached lady
II's Army and check out what they're up
to seeing smoke filling the area and
Morrow thinks they're trying to mess
with the animal smells before The Boar's
attack she mentions the humans are
setting up an obvious trap but the bores
are too proud to back down and will
attack no matter what even their leader
okoto okay all bores are being a bit of
an idiot I would solve all of our
problems by appealing to the B's
self-interest listen the bores won't
listen cuz as Moro said they're proud to
race due to their massive ego or as it
is known in psychology as high ego
strength this my good weees is a concept
that refers to a person's ability to
deal with their problems stress and
recover from setbacks having a strong
ego helps us to manage emotional
stability and deal with internal and
external stress in our lives without
resorting to unhealthy coping mechanisms
you know having one too many beers and
certain substances however people with
well developed ego strength tend to
share several essential characteristics
one they're confident in their ability
to deal with challenges two they're good
at coming up with solutions to Life's
problems and they have a high level of
emotional intelligence and are able to
successfully regulate their emotions
even in tough situations in this case
however since the bers don't know how to
deal with the problem they're facing
they're willing to die and achieve
nothing and this means that their High
ego is bordering on self-d delusion and
will be the cause of their own
destruction which is the problem if you
ask me I might as well make their lives
valuable in some way if I was more
tomorrow I would tell them that since
they're willing to die if it means
killing the humans I would tell them I'm
not going to stop you but let's do it in
a way that causes more humans to die cuz
I don't care about my own race I don't
care about you guys either but if you're
going to die you might as well die and
be more effective about it I would
create a better plan of attack against
lady iosi since they have many bores by
utilizing Guerilla Warfare hit and run
attacks that would be much better suited
for them yes I know the bores are strong
prideful race but if it means more
humans die at the cost of each one of
their own lives I think they might bend
a little bit to my way of thinking since
the have the advantage of longrange
weaponry and HomeField Advantage with
the way they have set up their defenses
which means there was no reason to let
them die for no reason we'll let them
die but not for no reason Morrow spots
the humans also cutting down trees
telling son that this will make the
bores more angry and not think clearly
but son decides to go help Oto and to be
his eyes because she just like ashitaka
she doesn't want to give up and suddenly
another wolf reaches her and hands her
the necklace from Ashi taka making her
all few and cuddly and adorable and
Morrow then commands these wolves to
stay with son while she goes to see see
the forest Spirit splitting up son
passes by the bore Army charge again and
finds out where she can find okoto
heading off to see him elsewhere Ashi
taka goes to meet a lady ibosi but
suddenly hears gunshots coming from the
opposite direction where iron town is
and it's really weird rushing there he
sees the town under attack by Lord aso's
Army rushing into to help he finds out
from Lady aoshi's women that they got
surprised while their leader was off
fighting the bores and now they can't
send out a messenger to warn her so what
do they do they hand him his weapon and
tell them that he better go and help
while they hold out but on the way there
a samurai Arrow strikes down yakul
causing ashitaka's hand to start
transforming changing him inside the
enemy shoots an arrow straight at him
but he suddenly catches it and sends it
right back reaching the battle between
the humans and the bores he smells the
Rotting Flesh thousands of corpses and
he tells the Iron Town soldiers that
their town is being attacked they tell
him that only lady ioshi can signal them
to head back but she left into the
forest to hunt down the forest Spirit
the GU reveals that lady ioshi is
actually being used by jico and they
also saw wolves earlier along with the
wolf girl son just then ashitaka finds
one of son's wolves trapped under the
pile of corpses he rushes to try and
save him and this Iron Town General
thinks he's a traitor and tries to
murder him but Ashi taka's friends
turned against him and help him free the
wolf about to head after lady iosi and
son this villager warns him that her men
belong to J and may try to kill him
leaving yakul with these people he tells
the wolf to go and find son while he
finds lady iosi meanwhile deep in the
forest son tries to rescue okoto but
sees him critically injured trying to
reach the forest spirit for help she
then senses something coming and spots
J's men in bore flesh camouflage being
blind and unable to smell the humans
okoto gets excited and thinks yay my
Warriors have come to help me but nope
that's not it with the last of his
strength he starts charging towards the
forest Spirit son begs him to stop and
tells him he's actually leading the
humans to the forest Spirit but Oto
doesn't listen the wolf warns son that
he is done for and they should abandon
him but son refuses and tells the wolf
to go tell her mother Morrow that the
humans are after the force spirit
because she will know what to do okoto
finally collapses in exhaustion and she
hears a wolf howl nearby signaling that
ashitaka is close the bad guys quickly
surround okot and try to stab him to
make him get up force him to cry out in
pain and he begins turning into a demon
son tries to stop him but she gets hit
with a sleeping Dart making her collapse
onto him getting absorbed into his
transforming demon flesh nearby ashitaka
hears son's wolf call out to them that
son is in danger rushing in to find her
he passes by lady ioshi and her men and
he tells her that Lord oano Samurai are
attacking iron to but she tells him the
girls can handle themselves because
she's headed for the forest Spirit
ashaka warns her that most of her men
have now left her side to head back and
everyone here is actually secretly on
J's side she thinks he's lying and tells
him they've already reached the lake
where the for spirit is and it's too
late to turn back now crap asitanga then
finds Morrow on her death bed and he
calls out for son and hears her call
back but something is wrong the floor
begins to rumble as okoto approaches him
but is now a fullon demon and sees the
humans and disguises behind him they
threaten Ashi taka to leave so the
forest spirits will come towards them
but he calls their Bluff telling them if
they try to harm him they will scare the
forest Spirit Away anyways he calls out
to son and rushes in to save her while
nearly getting shot he's Noble like that
son's wolves quick quickly rushed to
cover ashitaka giving him enough time to
bum rush okoto but he easily gets
overpowered and flung into the lake okay
that didn't turn out as much as I
thought it would now with no choice
Morrow uses the last bit of her strength
to attack OKO and save son while her
wolves push back the humans and suddenly
they spot the forest spirit in the
distance approaching them no don't do
that using this opportunity lady iosi
Firs her gun at it but it keeps walking
towards Oto and Morrow and it sets them
free with his job done it begins
transforming into this other horrifying
creature but lady iosi shoots one final
time blowing off it head J's men quickly
capture the head and its body explodes
everywhere moro's head jumps out to bite
lady II's arm off while everybody tries
to escape the area before the forest
Spirit kills them meanwhile with
ashitaka he wakes up underneath the
water and tells them they need to get to
the island son brought him to earlier
since water will slow the forest Spirit
down jumping into the water and taking
sa to the island he tells her that her
wolf mother has already Avenged her and
she should now try to uh move on he
tells lady iosi that he promised her
town that he would return her and he
promises to do just that begging son to
help she gets mad and thinks he's
helping the humans but he breaks her
mind and tells her that she's human what
a shocker and suddenly convinces her to
help them does that make sense the
forest Spirit begins swallowing up the
entire Forest looking for its head Ashi
taka and Son quickly reach iron town and
warn the people that they're screwed and
they need to escape to the lake because
if the forest Spirit goo touches them
they're all dead him and Son rush off to
catch Chico mid Escape but he tells them
that by Sunrise the forest spirit will
vanish forever so they just need to hold
on to its head until then but however
ashitaka says Nah and tries to fight him
and everyone quickly realized that
they're now cornered and about to die
well despite their good efforts they
went about this really dumb there was no
reason to cut it as close as they did
cuz look when Ashi taka ma boy went to
warn iron toown he stopped to warn the
girls about the incoming Forest that
stupid took over 19 seconds before
leaving to go to stop Chico during this
time if I was him since we're chatting
about our life story anyway we may as
well ask the iron toown girls to throw
us some Weaponry you know they got guns
they could probably spare us a few
they'd clear access to it since they
were in the middle of a major battle
having Weaponry in the first place would
have allowed us to take out jico and his
men from further distance say way I
would love to get this conflict over and
done with really quickly because I like
that way better than being chased by an
allout God so every second matters at
the last St ashitaka manages to steal
the head from Joo and return it at the
last minute causing the spirit God to
come crashing down on them causing a big
explosion it's a whole lot of mess
everywhere the sun rises and it
collapses on iron town but destroying
the nature of the forest as well a
little later Ashi taka and Son wake up
and seeing the forest back to its
original Glory my gosh that fixes itself
up quickly she tells him that the forest
spirit is dead but he says that it lives
on in the forest and blah blah blah he
also notices that his curse on his hand
is finally gone which makes everyone
happy is they decide to part ways and
son will go back to live in the forest
while ASI Taco here decides to stay in
Iron Town to help them rebuild because
he's stupid but he warns her that he'll
visit her often and makes our lowkey
excited H hooo but meanwhile deep in the
forest one little Kodama pops up
signaling that this Forest will soon
come back to its healthy old creepy self
but what do you guys think about the
video let us know what you like about it
and what you didn't like about it don't
forget to like subscribe and leave a
comment down below and as always don't
forget to check out our howt toe
playlist